(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Please draw
a cute cat on the box
with a speech bubble, saying howdy.
I would like it to be
wearing a cowboy hat.
I will tip $10 for listening
to my ridiculous requests.
(cat purrs)
- [Narrator] This is for Butters the pug.
You know he's a baller,
and he want's his (bleep).
I'd like an extra turkey patty
and five strips of bacon, no bun.
Home pug needs his meat.
- [Narrator] Can you please
spell congrats in pepperonis?
If the pepperonis don't fit,
then use jalapenos instead.
Can you please also include
a note with the delivery
that says congratulations on your new job?
Who cares if others get mad,
you won't have to see
their faces ever again.
- [Narrator] Last time,
you guys killed it,
absolutely awesome salad.
I want you to murder
that salad with croutons
and parmesan cheese.
Like, I want it to be offensive to people
that don't like croutons and cheese,
as much as you love to throw on there.
Have people look at that and be like whoa,
is that a salad with croutons,
or croutons with salad?
- [Narrator] I don't know Rick,
does sunny side up mean over hard?
Look here Morty, these here
breakfast people understand
the nature of their eggs.
If you just tell them you want over,
maybe you'd stop being such
a worthless piece of (bleep).
Jeez Rick, no need to be a jerk about it.
- [Narrator] I just want the
cheese with the (bleep) beef,
sour cream, and lettuce, that's it.
So, if you could, could
I just get that dubs
since I'm not getting the
salsa, jalapenos, and onions?
I'd greatly appreciate it,
and since I've ordered
from you guys a lot,
so has my boyfriend, 'cause
you guys are the (bleep).
(upbeat music)